[Applause]
say a vast number of soldiers and
military forces being amassed around
ukraine
but the second time in fact in less than
a year there were forces masked
around
the same areas in april they were
withdrawn to their barracks this time
around they've remained poised to
threaten potentially invade ukraine
[Music]
my guess is he will move in
he has to do something
so what the satellite images show is a
buildup of quite traditional military
equipment trucks armored vehicles
encampments for soldiers
but the thing i'm particularly
interested in is the extent to which the
russian federation if it is to invade
further commits its air force and its
air power to this point because i think
a land commitment by the russians would
probably not be enough to be able to
achieve a sort of a rapid
a rapid thrust into ukraine that
delivers a short sharp and very violent
very destructive message
[Music]
russia could enhance those forces
sending its troops over the border
uncontested perhaps even trying to
instill some kind of breakout operation
to those two separatist republics move
their borders further west and take more
territory
the next sort of
option that russia might have is to try
to take new territory and it could bring
forces in from multiple directions
[Music]
i think what russia and vladimir putin
be really after would be to defeat the
ukrainian armed forces in the field
inflict a crush on military defeats that
humiliates the ukrainians and by
extension uh creates concern that the
backing ukraine has from its allies in
the west the us and the uk is
insufficient to protect ukraine if
russia doesn't commit these troops to
battle
both sides nato and ukraine on the one
hand and russia on the other will try to
claim some kind of victory and i think
it's really important not to just jump
on the bandwagon and say well russia
never committed those troops to battle
russia has been deterred
actually what russia will probably say
that they have achieved and putin and
lavrov will say they've achieved is to
bring this question on further nato
enlargement to greater prominence than
perhaps it ever has
[Music]
you